Hello everybody. I hope that you're
good. Yesterday's plan worked out pretty
nicely, okay? Because uh we were saying
that as long as we were above the 1-hour
50 MA, then price was going to you know,
we were going to favor higher prices.
And our first target was going to be the
50% of the week. And if they could go
above it, then the liquidity pool at
31,200 would be next, okay? Didn't get
to the liquidity pool, but you can see
that you know, we were above the 1-hour
50 MA, and they did another push up
towards the 50% of the week. So, uh
these levels, you know, that projection
is completed, that level is hit. Now,
you might be wondering, what do you
think about this week? Let's go into the
4-hour time frame to see how it looks,
okay? Maybe in the 4-hour time frame
looks a bit better, but let me tell you,
okay? This week here,
I don't even consider it a long week.
Why? Because if you compare it to the
candle body, this week is not really
that important. All right? Yes, it's
still a $200 move, okay? So, it's a
pretty nice week, but you can see here,
this week here
is more
uh clear, okay? Because look at the
candle body, and look at the week, okay?
It doesn't happen the same here. Also,
this is something that I always tell to
the guys in the course.
If a week is created, this one, to fill
a previous week, then this week doesn't
need to get filled.
Okay? That's how the system works.
By the way, I'm going to open new slots
for the course next week, okay? So, stay
tuned into Twitter, but that's another
story. Now, the problem that I have here
is that they dumped,
but they didn't hit this liquidity pool
first, okay? And that's a problem for
me, and I'm going to tell you why. It's
a problem for me because if they would
have pumped, you know, filled the week
like they did, then retrace also this
liquidity pool, and dumped, and you
know, and now we are below the 50-minute
1-hour time frame, then I would tell you
guys, I'm favoring lower prices. Um I
think we're going to go to this level
here.
Okay? Why? Because you have here some
liquidity.
And also because that matches with the
4-hour 50 MA. Okay? This blue line will
tell you
this week
I'm going to go short.
That's what I would tell you, okay? But
uh I'm not sure, guys. Uh usually when
they leave for liquidity pool like this
at the highs, that is usually a signal
that they're going to revisit this
level.
Okay? Now, the question is are they
going to come again another attempt up
to retrace the liquidity pool before
dumping?
Okay? Or are they going to leave it for
later? So, for example, price could, you
know, dump and then it could make
another attempt to retrace that
liquidity pool and then continue
dumping, for example, okay?
Uh that's the question that you have to
ask yourself. That's what I'm trying to
figure out. If they're going to try to
come
to this liquidity pool first
before dropping.
Okay? Or if you if you're going to drop
first and start retracing these
liquidity pools on this Look at that.
They are massive, aren't they? These
liquidity pools
before retracing these what are the
highs, okay? That's what I'm trying to
figure it out. Anyway,
um this week uh it's been very nice to
short altcoins and I'm going to tell you
why.
The Bitcoin dominance, okay? This is
something that I've been talking about
for quite some time. Let's get there.
Daily time frame.
Um well, actually weekly time frame. I
was telling you guys, you know, we are
in this range.
And this time here
it didn't look the same as these
previous times.
Okay? Um I know some of you already have
heard me saying this, but I repeat this
for the new people in the channel.
These times here you could see that they
were sitting a week then dump, a week
dump, a week dump, a week dump, one
candle on a week dump. Here, they were
holding at the highs.
Okay?
This should have made you ask yourself,
you know, all those people in Twitter
saying we're going to see an old season
because we're going to go here.
Which by the way, these are not old
seasons. These are altcoins rallies.
I'll tell you what an old season is.
Okay?
This here
is an old season. This here is an old
season. This, this, this, this, these
are altcoin rallies. Okay? But anyway,
you can see it clearly in the chart how
this didn't look like it was going to
drop here, okay? It was looking
different, okay? So, that was what I
tell you
that the most likely thing was going to
go, you know, push above this range,
test it as support. It actually did it
here. If we zoom in, you're going to be
able to see there.
Okay? Check out there. Perfect. I It's
actually been perfect. Look at that.
Tested as support and then continue
going higher to 52%, okay? To this
candle here. That was
my idea.
And you can see price is right now up to
51.85%.
And of course, sorry. And of course, it
could continue even going higher.
But Bitcoin has to retrace, okay? The
Bitcoin dominance follows Bitcoin pretty
much.
But Bitcoin has to retrace. So, what I'm
thinking here, okay, is of course
Bitcoin should retrace sooner or later.
The Bitcoin dominance is going to
retrace, but the difference here should
be that now the Bitcoin dominance has
support here. Okay? And if it finds
support here and Bitcoin continues
dropping,
okay? And by continuing dropping, I mean
going to, I don't know,
uh 26K,
25K. Why not? It could happen, okay? So,
if that scenario happens and the Bitcoin
dominance can't hold above this zone and
not continue dropping, then altcoins are
going to get wrecked.
Okay? And that's a scenario that I've
been talking for quite some time. You
know that, guys.
Anyway,
I'm going to show you what I mean by
shorting
I'll fix the chart later. I'm going to
tell you what I meant by shorting
altcoins.
What you need to know is that if the
Bitcoin dominance is high,
okay? Like that high as right now, super
high, then when Bitcoin dumps,
okay? Let's go into the 4-hour time
frame.
When Bitcoin dumps,
to be honest, this wasn't a big dump in
the Asian session.
This was a
1.8%
dump, okay? But if you go to altcoins,
let's go for example to ADA, okay?
You're going to be able to see here
that this was
a 5 and 1/2% dump,
okay?
So, when the Bitcoin dominance is high
and you're looking for shorts, then it's
better to short altcoins. And I'm going
to show you more examples. Let's go for
example, I don't know, Matic. Let's
check Matic.
Okay?
Let's check. So, that would be from
here.
That's another 5 and 1/2% dump, okay? I
could continue showing you more.
I don't know about Chainlink. I don't
know what Chainlink did.
Let's see.
Probably going to be the same.
Again, around 4 and 1/2% okay? Let's
continue. Solana, maybe?
Let's check Solana.
5.1%
dump, okay? This is what I mean, guys.
When the Bitcoin dominance is high,
then
if you want to short, short altcoins. If
you want to long, long Bitcoin. It's as
simple as that, okay? And that's what
I'm going to be favoring until the
Bitcoin dominance drops, okay? As long
as it's going up and it's looking good,
then if you want to short short
altcoins, simple as that, guys.
Okay, let's go back to Bitcoin. In
Bitcoin,
well, I see in the chart right now is,
first of all, what I would like to go
deeply in shorts is to see a push here
to the liquidity pool, and then a dump,
okay? Then, this is what I would open my
shorts if we see a reaction to the
downside, okay?
Why? Because then
the all the imbalances to the upside are
filled,
and Bitcoin can I start to recover these
imbalances at the left, okay? More
things, if you go into the 1-hour time
frame,
you're going to be able to see here
what, okay? Or at least this is what I
think. Let's mark all these candles.
But, if you notice at the highs, large
green candle, large green candle, large
green candle,
large green candle. What happens after?
They bring price down. They bring price
down, again and again, okay? So, with
these large green candles,
what the price action is telling me is
that the market maker are building their
shorts here,
okay? Around this zone here.
This is where the market maker is, you
know, building their shorts.
So, uh as long as we don't break above
this level, 31,400,
okay? As as as long as we don't break
above this level, holding as support,
then
I'm going to favor lower prices from
this range over here, okay? That's my
idea at the moment. Um now, the plan is
where
do I open a short? Again,
ideally, after the liquidity pool gets
retrace, and then you start seeing price
reacting to it and going lower, okay? At
that moment, then you can or at least
that's what I plan to open my shorts.
Okay? But now, let's go into the 4-hour
time frame. Let me remove all this mess
that I've created.
Let's see.
Okay. If you go into the 4-hour time
frame, the chart is pretty simple, okay?
You have this level over here.
Let me mark it for you.
You have that level over here. That's
around 30k, okay? This level over here.
And if you lose this level, then the
next level is going to be this one. It's
going to be 29,500, okay? That's very
simple. So, if you lose this level,
of course, there's a chance that you do
a sweep of the lows, and then you come
back inside this level, test it as a
support, and push. But, if you see this,
okay? If you see a drop,
okay? Then price establishes below it,
and it doesn't come above it quickly,
then what you are looking for is a short
opportunity towards this zone here,
okay? Now, at this zone, let's see what
Bitcoin does. It could, you know, hold a
support. It could again sweep the lows,
or it could continue dropping, okay?
But, this should be your take profits.
Now, from here, also, what I found
interesting about this level
is that we have the 4-hour
50 MA, this blue line, okay? By the way,
you can change the settings here. If you
go to the
settings, inputs, time frame,
you can select the time frame that you
want that EMA to show on, okay? So, I
selected the 4-hour time frame. But, you
can see here that there is a bit of
confluence for our take profits if we
lose this level here, okay? You have
this
previous level where they bought from,
and you also have the 4-hour 50 MA. So,
this is a potential support zone if we
lose this one.
Okay? That's a setup that I'm looking
out for now. But, of course,
we want to go into Hyblock Capital.
We're going to try to see if we can see
anything else that helps us to identify
the potential next move.
Okay, we're in Hyblock Capital. 12-hour
liquidation heat map. First,
let's have a look at this.
Okay. We can see that we are between two
big liquidity zones, okay? That would be
the 30,700 zone to
That wouldn't go all the way to 31,200.
That's our liquidity pool, okay? Doesn't
get all the way there.
And to the downside we have the 30,000
zone. That that is also
a psychological number. All right, so
that also that's also our current
support 30,000. So if you lose that
level, then you should be aiming for
29,500 zone. And if we push up all the
way here,
I would ideally like to see, you know, a
follow-through towards 31K, that
liquidity pool, okay? That's what I'm
looking for now. Price action is quite
boring at the moment. Um
I think swing traders have to wait a bit
more,
in my opinion. And the scalpers Yeah,
scalpers are going to have a good time
in lower time frame, in the 15-minute
time frame, 5-minute time frame, because
we are in a range right now, okay? Now,
in the 7-days time frame, what do we
have here? Okay.
There is a lot of liquidity growing
here.
Uh 29,500,
okay?
Remember,
that is
our target if we lose 30K, right? And
I've already explained why. And to the
upside, 31,800.
Now, you can see that we are closer to
this level to the downside, so
in theory, it's more likely that we go
to this amount here, okay? To 29,500.
That's what
chart is
um
telling us.
So anyway, guys, let me mark these
levels, the important levels, in my
opinion, okay? You have here 29,500.
Um you also have this one here. I again
I mark them because I know that there
are stop losses here. I know that there
are stop losses here, okay? And also you
have here the 4-hour 50-MA. So those are
the important levels in the chart to the
downside. To the upside, of course, you
have this liquidity pool here at 31,200.
And now,
uh what you have to keep an eye on is
that if we drop,
you know,
below this level, is there is a chance
that it might be a deviation
before pushing price up again, okay?
But, if they lose this level,
okay? And it consolidates below
resistance,
then this is what you will see, another
drop towards this level here again. And
this level you'll see the same. It could
be a deviation
or again, it could be another drop,
consolidate, drop okay? So, this is what
you have to keep an eye on for these two
levels.
Um
I'm not in any positions yet in Bitcoin,
okay?
So, uh what I want to see,
I'll repeat myself, is a push here to
this liquidity pool,
and then hopefully,
if they come to this liquidity pool
before dropping price,
you know, and we see a reaction from
here, and we don't break these highs,
then this is where I would go into
shorts, okay? I'm targeting lower
prices. Um because yeah, I think that
the market maker is building their their
shorts here with these candles, okay?
That's at least what I think.
Um maybe wrong on this one. We'll see
what the price
uh delivers. Um then, for the day
traders that are trading today,
uh what I see here
within the trading sessions is that Asia
dumped here, okay?
You can see here, Asia dumped. Now, it's
the time for London.
Uh London is already pushing price too
much, so I wouldn't really like them to
push price be I above this level here,
okay?
Um then,
that would take us to
New York
to push price high, okay? Of course, I
don't know if this is going to play out,
but because for this I would need to see
London not really going
above this level here.
So, that means that in the next couple
of hours, I would like to see a retrace
here
in London, okay? So, then if that
happens and they come towards this level
here,
then that would be telling me that it's
likely that New York, you know, might
pump today a bit.
Right? Maybe a $500 move. And that's a
move that you could take advantage of.
But again,
uh I don't know if London is going to
stop here. Uh that's what I think for
the day traders. I don't see much going
on here because if you go into the
15-minute time frame,
I don't really see any wicks
in into the downside. Um it's not
looking like a good day for trading at
the moment. I'm going to wait until the
New York session to see if I can see
some imbalances that I can take
advantage of. But again, uh if I don't
see anything, then I won't trade today.
That's uh all I know. And for altcoins,
okay? If we are thinking that
Bitcoin could dump
and come again to these levels here, to
these liquidity pools, then my main
priority is to look for more shorts in
altcoins or to add positions to altcoin
trades.
Okay? This means that, for example, an
altcoin that I'm loving to trade now
into short is ADA,
okay? Cardano.
I'm trading this one like a bad boy.
I jumped into a short here at 0.2913.
I took some profits at 28
uh below this level here, 2850 2850-ish.
And I still have a very small position.
It's really a small, so I would really
like that price pushes up up a bit so
then I can add to my shorts.
Okay? Because I think that
ADA has this
um
wick over here. Many altcoins have this
wick as still without getting retraced.
You can see here. That's around 24.80,
sorry, 24.6. And I think that ADA will
eventually come here. So, I'm looking to
add into shorts. Okay?
Another one is LINK.
Let's go to LINK.
This is one that, you know, for the long
term,
I think it's a good coin, but
in the short term,
I shorted here, 6.22.
Almost at the highest, but there was
this week here that went to 6.38.
Uh but anyway, I'm right now into this
uh swing short. I haven't taken profits
yet.
And what I would like to is the price
starts to, you know, fill this um
liquidity pool over here.
Um maybe this one, too, okay? Those are
my plans for LINK. Also, you can see
here why I enter here is this zero line.
Support, support. Well, in this level it
gets uh tested several times. Support,
again tested here.
Support, support.
Um here, I think it acts as resistance.
And now it may be acting as resistance
again. Okay, that's why I chose this
level for LINK. Um so, anyway,
I think you should be looking for trade
opportunities in altcoins, and I'm going
to tell you why you should be looking
at.
If you go to the total three,
you want to trade altcoins that are not
outperforming the total three. What do I
mean with this, okay? Let me show you
this.
Uh so, basically, I want here
the 50 MA in the daily time frame. Okay?
You want to trade altcoins
that are looking like the total three.
Okay? That are looking weak, that they
are not outperforming the total three.
So, you don't want to trade altcoins
that are above
the daily 50 MA. You want to trade
altcoins that are below the 50 MA.
That's for example why I chose ADA.
Okay? Look at this.
It's looking very weak, okay? It didn't
even make to this level.
The total three is at here, okay?
It didn't even get there, and you still
have this week without getting filled.
Um I will have to go through the chart
to find more examples. Uh let me go
through it. So, you would have for
example, let's have a look. Uh don't
know.
MATIC maybe? MATIC, uh the price of
MATIC already reached the
um that week. So, I'm not looking for
Matic. Let's see more here. Solana
retraced the the 50% of the week and
then pushed.
Let's see XRP.
XRP neither.
Uh, it's got to be lower.
V chain above the daily 50 MA. I'm not
interested.
Oh, wow. This one is a very interesting
one, okay? AXS
or whatever it's called. You have here
this massive week. Okay? And 50% of the
week must be around here, 385. It's
below the 50 MA in the daily time frame.
So, this is for example a coin that you
could be looking for shorts.
Uh, well, for swing shorts, okay? Uh,
let's continue.
I've seen some uh altcoins that I
haven't updated for a long time.
All right.
Let's see if we can find more weeks. I
want basically a long week. For example,
this.
A long week and to be below the 50 MA.
This could be another example.
But let's see if we can find better
ones.
Let's have a look.
Ocean has been doing well.
All right. Oh, this one looks very good.
Uh, clay
or clay, I don't know how it's called. I
don't even know what this coin is about,
okay? Uh, very similar chart to um ADA,
okay? And to to 12.3 And it has this
very long week here, okay? The 50% of
the week must be here.
Around
uh 0.14.
That's around
to 0.14. Okay? And right now you're at
0.16. So,
this is another coin that you could be
looking to jump into swing shorts. All
right. Uh, this is what I'm trying to
figure it out.
And these are the type of altcoins that
I'm trying to find
to short when Bitcoin starts to retrace,
okay?
Uh of course it doesn't make much sense
to jump into swing shorts now. You want
to first go into the Bitcoin chart and
in the Bitcoin chart see
a clear signal. I don't know what I'm
doing here. Hang on. Here.
And in the Bitcoin signal you want to
see
a very clear
uh signal of a retrace. For example,
when can you jump into these uh altcoins
uh into shorts, okay? Um you're going to
You will lose some of the position in
price.
To me that's not a problem because then
I would know uh anyway that I'm taking a
high probability trade that is going to
give me a profit either way, okay? But
for example,
once Bitcoin drops below here,
drops below here, okay? Then here you
would have lost
the 4-hour 50 MA,
okay? And this support here, so then
you're going to start, you know, rolling
over to this liquidity pool,
to this liquidity pool, to this
liquidity pool. So, look at that how
much Bitcoin can drop, okay?
Bitcoin if Bitcoin loses this level,
okay?
Then Bitcoin can drop uh
2K
easily. Imagine what that means for
altcoins when you have the Bitcoin
dominance so high.
Okay? You know, those altcoins that I
showed you, either uh I think that one
was called Clay.
Uh
they would dump pretty hard, okay?
They would probably easily go again
towards these levels here, okay?
Either probably would come here, maybe
even here, too.
Okay? And these moves are very big moves
cuz this is a 7% move
and a 13% move easily in the example of
Clay. Let's go back to Clay.
Uh Clay. So, we said that we have this
week here.
It was a 0.14 in the daily timeframe,
okay? So, if Clay if Bitcoin starts to
roll over and loses the 4-hour 50 MA,
this coin, you know, is probably going
to go towards the wick. And we're
talking here
about another 15% move.
So, this is what I'm looking for now in
higher time frame. Um basically trying
to find a moment of weakness for
Bitcoin, that it starts to roll over,
loses this level, and if that happens, I
jump into shorts, but shorts in
altcoins.
Anyway, guys,
I don't want this video to get much
longer
cuz I feel like I'm a chatterbox. I've
been talking for ages. It's Wednesday. I
don't want to bore you. We're in the
middle of the week. There is going to be
more content coming this week. Krypton
always back, baby.
Thank you so much for watching,
and I'll see you soon.